DAVID TU: Hey.
This is David Tu.
I'm a network specialist
at Google Cloud.
Welcome back to What's
New in Networking.
Today we'll guide you through
our new load balancing
and service networking launches.
First our new features around
external and internal load
balancers.
Next we'll take a quick stop
discussing Traffic Director.
And we'll finish off our journey
with Private Service Connect.
Stay tuned.
First stop is our External
Network Load Balancer.
The Network Load Balancer is
a regional pass-through load
balancer that
distributes TCP and UDP
traffic among virtual
machines in the same region.
As you might know, the
network load balancer
leverages target pools
or target instances.
With the recent launch,
we've enabled the use
of regional back-end services.
Similar to target pools,
a back end service
defines how cloud load
balancing distributes traffic.
But now backend
service configurations
give you fine-grained
control over how
your load balancers behave.
It contains a set of values
like protocols, distribution
and settings, health
checks, and timeouts.
So what does this launch mean?
First, this launch
gets feature parity
for the same backend services
as other Google Cloud Load
Balancers, like our Global Load
Balancer or our TCP and SSL
proxy load balancer.
Second, it transitions
from legacy health checks
to unified health
checks, which allows you
to configure TCP health checks.
Third, it enables
connection draining.
And lastly, it enables
failover groups.
All right, now let's
move on to what's
new with the internal
network load balancer.
Prior to this launch,
if you were ever
required to send traffic to a
single internal load balancer
virtual IP, you were limited
to only one forwarding rule
per virtual IP address.
With this launch, you'll
now be able to configure
multiple forwarding rules
with the same virtual IP.
Now you'll have the
flexibility to define
different protocols, such as TCP
or UDP, to the same virtual IP.
In addition, you
have the flexibility
to have multiple forwarding
rules to the same virtual IP,
but exposing different ports.
This launch gives
you the ability
to have various forwarding
rules combinations pointing
to the same virtual IP.
Now that we've covered
our load balancers,
let's cover two new additions
to Traffic Director,
our fully managed traffic
control plane for service mesh.
Introducing TCP services
support for Traffic Director.
This feature enables you to
use Traffic Director to route
traffic to services that
expect non-HTTP traffic,
such as databases or
voice over IP services.
Those of you who have
TCP-based services
get global load balancing
for multi-region services,
such as cross regional
failover and overflow,
a fully managed control
plane for TCP traffic,
a consistent control plane
across L4 and L7 traffic,
and you can easily connect
workloads to external services.
For those of you that use
proxyless gRPC with Traffic
Director and need
additional visibility,
now you can, with observability
for proxyless gRPC.
You're able to access
monitoring and tracing
metrics that help you solve
configuration and networking
issues with your deployment.
Best of all, you can export
these metrics to cloud
monitoring and cloud trace.
You can then build
dashboards and charts
and even use them as a
basis for automating alerts.
Our last feature is
Private Service Connect
for Google APIs.
Prior to this launch,
there were two ways
of connecting to Google APIs.
The first is over
the public internet.
This requires your client
to have a public IP
or go through NAT to hit
a public API endpoint.
The second was to configure
private Google access.
Private Google access
removed the requirement
to have a public IP
or go through NAT.
Now your clients can
privately route traffic
to private endpoint IPs
that Google defines.
With the launch of
PSC from Google APIs,
you have the ability to
create multiple custom
endpoints of your choosing.
Now you get more control over
which APIs hit which endpoint
and it remains completely
private to your VPC.
And that's what's new in
networking for load balancing
and service networking.
Thanks for sticking
around till the end.
I welcome you to start
using these features
and be sure to take
a look at the links
below for guides
on how to use them.
Stay tuned for the next
What's New in Networking.
[MUSIC PLAYING]